- Après plus d'un an
de pandémie, beaucoup de jeunes
ne vont pas très bien. Privés
de leurs amis et de leur sport,
plusieurs adolescents
sont en quête de sens.
- Le facteur commun,
c'est je dirais une espèce de
perte de points de repères.
- Stress, anxiété, troubles
alimentaires, idées suicidaires.
Certains ont développé de graves
troubles de santé mentales.
À Québec, 25 enfants
et adolescents avec
des diagnostiques d'anorexie ont
été hospitalisés depuis
le mois d'août.
- Actuellement, on est autour
du double des consultations
habituelles. C'est absolument
inquiétant, c'est la pandémie
des adolescents.
- À l'hôpital Ste-Justine
de Montréal, les adolescents
hospitalisés pour troubles
alimentaires en 2021 ont été
4 fois plus nombreux que
la moyenne des dernières années.
- Ceux qui arrivent jusqu'à
l'hopital, jusqu'au cabinet
du pédiatre, même jusqu'à être
hospitalisé, il faut bien
se rendre compte que par
définition c'est
la pointe d'un iceberg.
- Le problème est le même
partout au Canada.Les hôpitaux
pour enfants notent deux fois
plus d'hospitalisations
pour des tentatives
de suicide, trois fois plus
pour abus de substances.
Et pour ceux qui demandent
de l'aide, l'attente est longue,
les délais se comptent en mois,
et même en années,
dans le réseau publique.
Des professionnels du Québec
font donc front commun :
ils lancent une pétition
et publient une lettre ouverte
pour demander au gouvernement
d'agir rapidement.
- Le but de la lettre,
c'est vraiment de dire qu'on
veut que tout soit fait pour
améliorer l'accessibilité à des
soins vraiment spécialisés pour
traiter des problèmes de santé
mentale.
- Pour y parvenir,
il faudra bonifier les salaires,
selon elle. Les psychologues
du réseau public québécois
accusent un écart de salaire
de près de 30 $ de l'heure avec
leurs homologues de l'Ontario.
Rien pour séduire
les doctorants.
- Il y a seulement 25 %
qui viennent en raison
des conditions de travail.
- Pour que la santé mentale des
jeunes s'améliore il faudra que
tous mettent la main à la pâte
- Il y a le principe qui dit
pour s'occuper d'un enfant ça
prend un village. C'est vraiment
ça actuellement.
- Ici Camille Carpentier Radio-
Canada Lévy